un tiers des français estiment vrai
qu'il est nécessaire de donner de
l'argent de poche aux enfants pour les
faire participer aux tâches familiales
c'est bourdin direct vous explique tout
cela oublier nous parler des enfants qui
est dommage la question est ce qu'il
faut leur donner un peu d'argent par ont
repoussé les offres inciter les enfants
personne sur trois se dit prête à
rémunérer son enfant en échange de sa
participation aux tâches ménagères de
façon quotidienne à la maison les autres
disent banon ça va de soi c'est normal
de mettre la table de faire son lit
après il ya des tâches plus
exceptionnels comme ton de la pelouse ou
laver la voiture là un français sur deux
moi j'avais deux euros quand dans ces
cas là oui bon alors qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
est-ce qu'il faut rémunérer les enfants
ou est ce que finalement ça fait partie
du jeu ils vivent à la maison et donc il
débarrasse la table ils rangent leurs
chambres contre rien walou
nada rien qu'est ce qu'on en pense
gilles pour moi tout ce qui fait partie
de la vie quotidienne de la famille
débarrasser la table est le couvert
faire la vaisselle on ne rémunère pas
encore assez exceptionnel laver la
voiture allait faire quelque chose
dehors par exemple de rares ou de moins
commun là on peut donner ce qui
ressemble à de l'argent de poche mais il
faut expliquer à l'enfant aussi on lui
donne pas de l'argent parce qu'il fait
quelque chose qu'on valorise son travail
d'accord elle a quel âge votre fille 11
ans 11 ans donc si si vous lui demandez
de faire quelque chose d'un petit peu
extraordinaire vous la rémunérer oui
elle peut pas sortir dehors tout seul
mais si elle fait quelque chose je ne
n'hésiterait pas lui donner bien coraux
mais pour l'instant elle n'a rien
d'accord très bien mais là vraiment il
veut pas qu'est ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on
en pense c'est comme pour tout si on
veut du résultat il faut donner des sous
moi j'estime qu'il faut donner des sous
pour vous redonner de l'argent à votre
fils
oui mais c'est pas pour ça qui fait des
tâches ménagères mais j'ai besoin il
faut savoir que chez nous alors c'est la
culture corse pense que s'il ya des
corses qui nous écoute mais enfin il y
en a peut-être plein d'autres qui vont
se reconnaître
1 nous on donne beaucoup de d'argent
enfants parce qu'on a toujours peur qui
manquent et surtout garçon je sais pas
pourquoi c'est le plus les garçons que
les filles
daoudi hammami à tata à machin paf il
arrête pas de nous appeler mais du coup
il débarrasse la table il fait pas
si pas trop non mais ça il est gentil un
super sympa oui bah c'est pas pareil
partout
ben non menphis mais comment ça non mais
je vais encore me faire noël encore est
très attaché à dire que vous êtes en
train de me dire que parce que vous avez
un enfant qui est un garçon ou 50 des
objets de débarrasser la table de faire
la vaisselle ni de ton lit je la fais
tourner enfin si vous avez vous l'auriez
demandé de faire tout ça bat pour lui
apprend pour plus tard ribéry n'a pas à
son amoureux futur il pourrait aussi le
faire
j'ai peut-être qu'il le fera mais s'il
le fait pas faut qu'elles puissent se
marier mais votre aîné mais pardon alors
attendez de votre fils oui d'accord il
va il va avoir une chérie je le souhaite
tout le bonheur du monde d'accord si sa
chérie a été élevé en comme une femme
forte qui mais qu'elle lui dit c'est
quoi ton lit tu le fais tout seul mais
il change et à l'échangé vélo ça va pas
ou quoi il va pas le pauvre merde
vous plaisantez non mais il pourra
l'aider il va l'aider il remontait le
drive vous regardez les trucs à
l'ancienne valérie mais comment ça la
modernité regarder mais enfin ce pardon
mais on n'est pas obligé non plus
d'élever ses enfants à l'ancienne en
disant qu'il ya des différences entre
les garçons et les filles que la fille
elle doit faire le ménage et le garçon
et doit attendre en lisant journal lui
doit bien s'occuper d'elle il faut
qu'ils travaillent il faut qu'ils
s'occupent au ciné get est pas dans la
merde
personne ne fera rien
[Applaudissements]
bon ok tard il va pas la faire changer
là dessus et me mais est ce qu'on donne
un peu de sous non pas mais non
seulement pas déjà qu'on est en train
d'essayer de faire une société de
feignants donc non je suis désolé
débarrasser la table faire le lit faire
la vaisselle et des mamans passer
l'aspirateur bien évidemment qu'on n'est
pas payé du tout ce n'est pas de vous
n'avez pas à les abolir un franc ou un
franc cinquante ou de francs
l'accouchement un truc exceptionnel
comme laver la voiture ou où j'avais la
voiture donc ça va être très mal
interprété bien sûr vous faire des pipes
à mon beau père parce qu'il fumait la
pipe à dakar et préparer la pipe à ce
que l'on talend tabak
c'est une vraiment surtout par bulgari
bienveillant largeur de chaussée
rémunérés pour ça bien sûr mais aidé ma
main monde
allez stop amis bizarre un couple à on
arrête là j'ai embrassé offert la maman
tout ça allez vous êtes familier chez
nous seul ou d'aller monde que nous
vendent emilie francesca son châle ou
pas ça souvent autre chose moi je vous
vends du rêve
arrêtez de payer les enfants devraient
inclure l'argent dans la famille comment
faire lâcheté des robots travaillent des
gens qui travaillent pour vous faire des
robots pas des gens mais c'est un peu
nous on n'a pas encore des robots qui
débarrasse la table et on aime ou qui
passent l'aspirateur à wilairot d'accord
et après c'est moi je suis bizarre je
vais donc donc je résume en gros quand
il s'agit des tâches on va dire
quotidienne et on ne rémunère pas les
enfants on leur dit que c'est laid les
règles de la maisonnée
elle paye pas de loyer thierry billet
vous un petit peu vous donnez combien
par exemple votre six mois pas beaucoup
mais ma famille je suis beaucoup
d'accords moi j'ai essayé de tenir jusqu
ici mais je vois qu'il a les poches
pleines abandonne un peu au travers de
ce que vous en pensez est-ce qu'il faut
rémunérer ses enfants pour les tâches
ménagères à la maison est ce que c'est
une bonne idée ou bien est-ce que c'est
n'importe quoi mais où et n'importe quoi
68% du bon français ça sur ce coup là
moi j'ai dis pas pour l'étagé des
rémunérés en général
petit sourire
[Rires]